hey this is me home stroll a few days
ago during this walk I noticed something
so I started taking pictures of it
eventually I got my co-workers to join
in Mac took this picture and Agnes took
this one what we all noticed was this
font if you've somehow managed to never
see it on a storefront you've definitely
seen it elsewhere because it's
everywhere strip away the candy wrappers
movie posters album covers and corner
store signs and you're left with this
typeface
it's called Cooper black and the story
of how it became so popular has
everything to do with its versatility
because these letters have been around
for a century's worth of changes in
technology and pop culture
[Music]
to set the stage for the story
I talked to Stephen Heller bear with me
while I move to another part of the
apartment among other things he's
written like a library's worth of books
about design ok I'm back and this is
Bethany heck I am a designer who writes
about typefaces she runs the font review
journal where she deconstructs the
history and design of notable typefaces
like Cooper black if you give me like
two minutes I can run and find an actual
like physical piece of wood type and I
can talk through some of this well she's
doing that let's travel back in time a
hundred years to the city of Chicago
where our story begins
it's 1919 right after World War 1
advertising was reaching an early zenith
at that point because with the end of
the war there was a great resurgence of
product and demand the two dominating
materials for commercial printing were
wood and metal wood was cut out of the
end pieces hard wood they were usually
large size typefaces that were used for
large-scale advertising and posters the
bold typefaces you see in old wanted
posters those were made from wood type
metal was the process that was created
by Gutenberg when he designed the type
for his Bible each individual character
was physically formed into words and
those words were cast into tiny lines of
text those molds allowed for smaller
more precise blocks of type that's the
kind of type that was used for most
commercial purposes from book publishing
to magazine publishing by the turn of
the 20th century huge Rube Goldberg like
machines called linotypes drastically
sped up this process
this is the world Oswald Cooper
Chicago's preeminent letterer and
illustrator lived in in 1918 after years
of making custom hand lettered ads for
car companies and banks he designed a
fully-formed
typeface dubbed Cooper it took a classic
Roman form and softened to the edges
seeing promising Cooper's design and the
prior success of his lettering work the
type foundry Barnhardt brothers and
Spindler asked him to make a bold
display typeface based on the font
around 1920 Oswald Cooper released
Cooper black and it was an immediate hit
it was used for newspaper headlines and
large-scale posters it sold cars
cold medicine music lessons turntables
and ginger ale with Cooper black it was
like somebody took an air pump to tire
and blew up that tire I mean this ad for
Cooper Black credits the font for
getting five thousand customers into
their clients new store on opening day
and in countless reviews it was
considered the most popular typeface
design of the time so what made it work
so well for one its curves perhaps the
most unconventional aspect of the curves
are that willingness to be unafraid to
curve the bottom parts of the letter
forms so if you look at the bottom parts
of the stems of the a like there's no
flat edges on that which is very strange
if you look at most typefaces they have
flat bottom somewhere even Cooper blacks
imitations like gaudi heavy and papst
extra bold fail to fully break tradition
you want that consistent line for
legibility and so the fact that Cooper
doesn't have that means that it's very
forgiving to irregularities like the
baseline serif of one character
naturally flows right into the curve of
another even when the characters are
slightly uneven those irregularities
look more like mistakes than quirks and
straighter edge designs the fact that
Cooper doesn't necessarily need to be
laid in a straight line to look good is
an advantage let's talk about this weird
F it's an identifiable feature of Cooper
black turns out it's pretty genius draw
a rectangle around that F and you have
to think like okay I've got a draw of
really bold F
and I only have this rectangle of space
to play with you've got the crossbars
and then you've got the hook at the top
and the serif at the bottom you're kind
of like running out of space the shape
of this negative space in the ascender
allowed Cooper to make the F as bold as
possible for as much as possible while
still maintaining legibility which
wasn't always the case for heavy
typefaces of the time this is actually a
good example like this is a very bold
four and you can see that like the
counter space and there is like really
tiny the tiny Ness is what makes the
floor look bold and heavy but that four
could get sort of like filled up with
ink and then essentially vanish these
negative spaces within each character
made Cooper black incredibly light and
friendly while still commanding
attention the fact that it worked both
big and small was a huge selling point
every character of Cooper black has its
own little quirks the G is always the
thing that I think about first it has
like this sort of anthropomorphic
quality I think it looks like a duck now
that you say that like the cute kind of
looks like a snail weird at any rate I
think the letter that shows just how fun
and functional Cooper black can be has
to be the Oh a lot of typefaces have a
vertical stress so the oval inside would
just point straight up and down
Cooper's tilts back and while it looks
off-kilter on its own when placed in a
word or phrase it always seems to
compliment the letters around it the
central conflict that a type designer is
facing is how do I make something that
feels cohesive as a whole design system
as opposed to a beautiful collection of
letters somehow Cooper achieved both
oswald cooper believed cooper black was
at its best when there was thin spacing
between the words and not much letting
between the lines basically it worked
best when the letters were all cramped
together but that sometimes posed a
problem even when cooper black was first
designed like just the act of squishing
type together tight was like in some
cases extremely difficult or impossible
to do in the 1950s to dramatically new
ways of printing made it easier to push
letters closer together in that thrust
cooper black into the second half of the
20th century there was a basic change in
the material of which type is made a
change from lead to paper or film the
first was photo type hot metal
typecasting was replaced by film strips
in dark rooms and by the early 1960s
machines like the photo type oz etre
were small enough to fit in local print
shops the other was the invention of dry
rub transfers which just required a
ballpoint pen and a piece of paper it
was perfect for customizing headlines
letter set the company that made them
marketed it as fast simple and
economical these two technologies opened
up graphic design to more adventurous
compositions something wood and metal
had struggled to do and cooper black
flourished it thrived as always in
advertising it's friendly curves fit the
tongue-in-cheek aesthetic of the 1960s
and 70s but it also showed up in
magazines movies and hundreds of album
covers Pet Sounds was like the
quintessential setting just look at the
way the D works with the E and the Y and
boys fits so nicely over the oh it
it's fluidity is what makes it special
and it's boldness makes it special I
think all type designers would come in
and say like they have an idea of how a
typeface is is meant to be used but I
think that a typeface
doesn't really reach its full potential
until it's put into somebody else's
hands because Cooper black was readily
available in letras at int I posit or
catalogs it was no longer just in the
hands of professionals and designers it
was in the hands of the DI wires of the
counterculture movement it seamlessly
jumped from Burger King to underground
posters and magazines and became a
staple the idea of using something
that's basic vernacular but using it
with intention to make a statement is
something that you see throughout design
or cultural history
these early hip-hop posters are actually
the perfect example of Cooper blacks
adaptability and its legacy like take a
look at this one it doesn't really
matter that these are two lowercase LS
because the S fits so perfectly next to
them and the types ability to be
squeezed as tightly as possible and
still be incredibly legible holds up
even under extreme circumstances it's
always fun to look at something that's
used an assertive lowbrow way and then
to realize that this isn't like some
cheap tacky thing this is actually like
very good
that's why Cooper black is just as
popular today as it was when it was
first made from corner store signs and
fashion brands to food packaging
grassroots movements and hip-hop album
covers
Cooper's ability to work as like rebel
and letterings and in photo type and as
movable type and also now like in
digital that's why it's everywhere and
that's something that Oswald Cooper
couldn't have predicted
[Music]
you